the five films nominated tenacity
tonight take us from a vision of the
future to a village in Russia to one
Street in Texas to many streets in New
York and to the court of the Czar's who
then can say that films do not have a
broad spectrum and subject matter
philosophy point of view that is the
measure of the vitality of the movies
and equally a measure of their
potentiality the films nominated are a
Clockwork Orange
a Hawks film limited production Warner
Brothers Stanley Kubrick producer
fiddler on the roof
mirrors Cartier productions United
Artists Norman Jewison producer the
French Connection D'Antoni productions
20th Century Fox Philip D'Antoni
producer The Last Picture Show BBS
productions Columbia Steven J Friedman
producer Nicholas and Alexandra a
horizon picture productions Columbia Sam
Spiegel producer may I have the envelope
please
the winner is the French Connection
Phillips Santonio
that's it obviously a great honor to
think that the French Connection will
rank with all the pictures that have
come to this particular place in the
history of the Oscars on behalf of
Billie freaking I want to personally
thank all the members of our cast and
crew 20th Century Fox and of course the
Academy it's I still don't believe it
thank you very much